hi guys Alyssa be crazy I'm Dan Seibert
and I'm Ryan Wright we're gonna watch
the trailer for far cry 4 mmm oh my god
uh real quick if you're not aware it's
the steam summer state a steam summer
sale going on right now you get all of
the far cries for 15 [ __ ] dollars oh
wow yeah I just bought all of them so I
am gonna be playing the crap out of them
to prepare for this I'm ready to get
hated right now cuz I can admit right
here right now I don't know what the
hell Far Cry is I haven't a clue you
will know soon though you guys know how
six minutes of sorta the last one with
my sister my sister got it and just kind
of finished it in like two days and then
called me and after she crawled out of
her cave and had me play it coming
advocate
you gotta come I was like all the light
nourishment has been okay for so long
playing the game cuz once you enter you
can't leave yes yeah I wish I knew you
guys were talking about so kay
why is this gonna be
it's Healy soft is my favorite it's not
even the key agree yeah they know how to
do a presentation to get done
just like I'm pretty that is
among
I feel like if somebody asked for my
passport in that situation I would hand
it over to them because little sketch
like if you made it into Carl ready
you've probably already been asked for
it sure the module will do you know Ryan
this games about getting passports
that's it passport take it okay just
kind of scary oh yeah
this is know where the stood here Oh
steeds [ __ ] today yeah oh dude [ __ ] what
are these smugly don't run away
oh just in case you're ever in this
situation never run never run let's
alert
Oh
watch it - yeah it don't matter how it
matters
just like so enthralled by everything
with happening
it's clay it is clay and you nailed it
he's very fun eminently yes and then the
sake stop the bus
yes stop the bus why is it that
important that he has a helicopter
because I'm very particular with Malik
doctor as a sign above studies he is the
villain shoot stop
shoot do those words sound say letter go
out of control I'm sorry what'd you say
oh good things get out of control
oh that's why he has a helicopter that's
why he's got a helicopter yeah course
you just leave his hearing money he
didn't completely fine it up yeah
I recognize those eyes anywhere once
again just I'm so sorry about this press
is supposed to be haritaki but the
game's makes birdie waiting for you
ain't me in-game I'm not sure it looks
like a new game the intro who is this
hmm
is this your plus one strong silent type
like it
I am he's terribly embarrassed about all
this this was supposed to be very simple
but you know if you are now do but of
the moment I want you it's a little
little sorry let me take a selfie
don't worry about a thing my boy this
will soon be behind us it'll be off on a
grand adventure because I have cleared
my calendar fees you and I
oh cocaine ah very nice I give this
trailer not really trailer presentation
five out of five Alyssa be crazy stars
huh Ryan says this is right haha Dan's
like okay I don't have a rating system
it looks awesome that's it it's really
really cool I love it that was uh that
was quite gripping the whole time
actually I was really pulled in yeah is
like watching a real movie this uh I
remember as I kind of said during that
it is like that's the first five minutes
of the game oh yeah totally yeah yeah
the intro it's really hit miss with
intros for me like some of them are
really good like I've been a fan of like
all the fable intros just because
they've been really gripping I like
these even more under some of them I'm
not a fan of but Ubisoft you know fable
guys and like it like Assassin's Creed
like there are certain ones that tend to
get it right and Far Cry gets it right
every time Ryan Wright this game's gonna
be awesome for another reason I covered
this in one of my videos but if you have
Far Cry 4 and you say have a friend that
happens to be online with you on the ps4
and he's like hey I really like to play
with you and you're like great do you
own the game and he's like no it's like
no problem he can join your game without
having to own the game what yeah you
don't have to all own Far Cry 4 to like
play with each other no it's awesome no
it's awesome that's so good oh you said
play with each other
very cool we learned a lot of good
things today yeah right we buy it I will
buy it
Hey right bye yes
bye right bye red hmm alright guys if
you're new to the channel thank you so
much for telling me about this trailer
if you're new to the channel please
subscribe and uh uh subscribe to Alyssa
be crazy cuz she's [ __ ] nuts she's
over here no she's [ __ ] up in there
long as it goddamn insane asylum that's
how crazy Elissa be that's where we're
going after this yeah soon we got a lock
her back up
oh yeah yeah I want to go back there and
scary and dark sorry that's what the law
says after you're done filming that
cyber channel over here that's telling
you some a whole dimension it's cyber
nedick's cyber jeans
Cyberdyne anything cyber I think of that
is that cyber channel mm-hmm right
awesome
and we're the real rejects which is that
ones up there oh I'm ready
I'm on I want to give some shoutouts
it's a fresh thing I just started mmm
Stanley forever idk what took me so long
to subscribe I guess it's cuz I just
realized I thought I was touching Dan's
hand nevermind it's cuz oh now we're
touching hands because I didn't want to
flow with the trailers of movies I
didn't want to see anyways but now XD
i'ma subscribe just because of Ryan
right oh yeah dude that deserves a dick
suck you're gonna get one from me Marie
what the [ __ ] every single time I'm
filming something you gotta do something
to make it impossible for me to film
Jesus why do i why don't you over say to
yourself is sorry we had such a good
it's like all I like doing is bullying
you do you think this makes I'm happy I
do okay
anyway Stanley forever I have sorry for
Murray's annoyance look I wanted to say
cool name by the way
and I want to say that thank you you
know I I actually know what it's kind of
like to be in that weird position where
I like watching this guy's videos but do
I really want to subscribe and I get him
that a lot I do I'm very picky about who
I subscribe to you know selective very
selective any stroke I'll tell you this
Stanley forever
I'd subscribe to you oh that's a pretty
thing that's happening right now
mr. optimist 247 hey bro can I have a
shout-out let me answer that question
for you yes yes you can have a shout-out
no problem bro we got you covered we got
you covered we'll give you one we'll
give you one one day yeah one day we're
gonna give you a shout-out dude yeah
which I know mr. optimist 247 sometime
later on you're gonna get us talking
about you something
it's gonna happen to everyone rose up to
play you look for it you won't tell you
look out for it mr. optimist 247 you
have to watching all of them now from
here until eternity yeah then finally on
your deathbed but one day we'll shout
out mr. optimist two four seven just
don't no one's gonna be just no one's
gonna be Daniel Perez same question can
i have a shout out please um yeah yes
again maybe one day Daniel any one day
one take but Daniel Perez you look kind
of young I don't know if you're old
enough to be watching this channel it
can get pretty raunchy they can get
raunchy says my mother who apparently
watches every one of these yeah yeah
this was a great to skipper here but let
me tell you something Daniel for us
here's why you might get a shout out one
day because I started watching really
just things I shouldn't be watching when
I was probably your age scar scar me but
made me into the man I am today so if
you're watching those comedies I take it
all back
continue watching man is we're gonna be
[ __ ] awesome one day grow up to be
just like Ryan right yeah everybody
wants with his Batman pajamas yeah yeah
comment on those earlier when we copper
Ito a black guy said it was awesome
cancer Batman too anyway Daniel Perez um
yeah well um we'll think about giving
you a shout-out okay Daniel Perez it's
on the docket where we might mention you
just don't know where we're gonna say
your name again keep a lookout watch em
all you'll never know what look I you
never know yeah we might not even know
when we're giving you a shout-out right
it's a surprise shout out to everybody
yeah